a time here
they were lucky that wasn't turned over
Anthony Edwards
the top he does finish
filthy
there have been very few in-game dunks
that have looked like that put down on a
poster
[Applause]
Gordon defends on a switch crossover
three he got it
and Edwards starting to flex
here in Minneapolis
[Applause]
defeated by McLaughlin
Spruce on the Move got oh
[Applause]
what a SWAT
Edwards
oh the step back on Spruce oh baby
wolves not as sharp as they need to be
defensively Edward
[Music]
[Applause]
Edwards driving
[Music]
[Applause]
kids
this is amazing Anthony Edwards loaded
up and unpacking the TNT Jim the kings
are winning the second chance scoring
battle 14-6 in this game
Edwards right down the lane with the
stuff Kevin wrong
all right
get it in for towns back from McLaughlin
the bounce to the outside the jumper
good
[Music]
you know here's the thing as Russell
company
[Applause]
by McGee
and Booker Edwards comes over and says
get that shot out of here
let's see tyus Jones slips Balls to the
floor he doesn't do that very often turn
it over Edwards he can do that
I mean even Allen Iverson I mean like
just they've had some really great
Anthony Edwards sniffed out the steal
here look out Anthony Edwards
that was fun that was fun
they swam like a pack of wild dogs
Edwards
to work it in
the steal Edwards got it off in time oh
are you kidding me
Edwards the steal the three and these
type of plays right here like not boxing
out the foul line and give them
opportunities like this watch out oh
Anthony
is yeah don't jump
just because of last night yeah they
started off well but then the legs would
catch up a little bit
[Applause]
major elevation
eight quick coins for friends LeBron is
two of five
Shooters got it the cutting heximately
and another block Caldwell Pope off this
deal Edwards trying to get back and he
does what a rejection from Anthony
Edwards
now Edwards running the break euros and
finishes and Timberwolves fans have kind
of had a front row seat on the
differences of drop coverage especially
when you have oh my God
just hopped up and slammed that one down
now a switch Edwards towns didn't expect
it Edward's forced to kick it out
Russell Transit a long range hit Edwards
Oh What A Move by Anthony Edwards
gates are roller skates beds
[Applause]
Carl Anthony towns
terrific guy pass up ahead here's the
excellent point oh the windmill Anthony
Edwards and this Minnesota team for the
first time since there is dust up and
they've got him suspended all the way
Edwards what a block and Nas Reed scores
his brother he got a fingertip on that
here's Edwards attack Eagle Baseline
froze oh my
incredible how did he make that shot
Anderson on him
[Applause]
McCollum down the lane whoa
get it out of there you have the right
Arkin spin or you can kiss it off the
gas without using the Box
rolls out of 16-4 run they force the
turnover Edwards yeah ants are venomous
Here Comes Jayden McDaniels
[Music]
Edwards down the lane oh Anthony it
hurts yo elevated and hammered he got up
so high that was a little
miscommunication go past Jason Terry in
a few weeks
[Music]
Edwards number of fools All Glass he
cannot be contained